yeah welcome to this video playing seh
from Antarctica I don't really buy that
but it's a cool flag okay we cut them
attached defense iam I've played enough
rather classical manner here with e3 and
trying to exploit the bishop pair
long-term you will probably play em casa
Luke f6 g6 some no maybe not you can
also play em like he's doing with c5
it's the more reality is stategic lien
Clyde wait but this is this is rare
because well putting up all the parts in
the center basically means we will have
some exchanges and this this should
really favor favor white because of the
bishop they are opening up the position
in the center is pretty favorable
threatening note he doesn't react to it
okay I thought I was threatening to take
the five here maybe he has some idea
with night b3 enter and maybe Jay yeah
well i would still grab it
yeah an IP three could be a problem
especially considering that Bishop
ephors is also possible if you move the
night they especially form yeah great
yeah just one of those days he didn't of
course plan any of that he just stumbled
into this okay
Bishop c4 the night before wasn't really
necessary he could yeah he could place
it wherever basically now I got this in
this piece and he takes be one I take
before the night is hanging here and you
should have just played night a five or
something like that okay if I play
Bishop d2 he might he might change on f3
player d 8 and my back records I can go
to see three okay okay then then Bishop
d3 is okay I also could play 95 on IG
five
came through 28 jackin take and play
here there's no no back rack made
anymore and the most important thing is
his rook cannot enter my position at all
try to and now we can but I get the
podium check I cannot play g6 just
please pin yes that one mm but i guess
ii form should be fine it's a it's a
passer on your form okay let's see this
is a useful move anyway yeah and now the
King the king is cut cut off
Bishop f seven and then e 5j
yeah it just it just it just promotes I
think black resign you know yeah this
was very lucky if it does not play night
before I think I just lose yeah this is
probably mistimed I should I should play
this I should just play Quincy to hear
of course you know I just I just can't
play Quincy to attending b4b should be
too I black is basically busted here's
because this is all very weak f5
especially is just terrible in the
structure in addition of threatening
look takes d5 something like that
winning the Queen yeah this is just just
bad computer claims its equal I don't
understand it you just you should just
play that this is also the computer move
but the cop says that this is still okay
for white hmm yeah it's may be playable
I've got I've got strong square cm maybe
I wouldn't really think it's equal but
it's playable yeah this is probably not
working I'm just yeah I'm just winning
winning material yin and this is rather
easy win 95 is even better but this is
was was completely sufficient this end
game is so rather easy because at the
end I always get the upon all right
thanks for watching